all right as per usual well predictably
the Despicable socialists in the
Democratic party they wasted no time
revealing their true colors in the wake
of a crisis members of the squad are
Under Fire for calling a deescalation
and a ceasefire in Israel meanwhile even
have Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
is facing a backlash for her weak
response refusing to even acknowledge
that Israel was under attack or even
condemn the Hamas terrorists for this
unprovoked brutality anyway here with
reaction former un Ambassador 2024
Republican presidential candidate Nikki
Haley maybe maybe I'm old-fashioned and
and maybe this is not particularly
popular uh the fact that we spend
billions of dollars a year on the United
Nations and I and I know you the
Ambassador um for an organization that
has a history of virulent anti-Semitism
and anti-americanism I'm not sure why we
we fund that organization
can you help me
out well first of all you mentioned
members of the squad and you mentioned
Whitmer and they would get along just
fine at the United Nations as
anti-israeli as they are but what I'll
tell you is yes the UN is a farce we saw
the Secretary General come out and say
that we should do a ceasefire and I
would say at the security Council when I
was there is would any of you do a
ceasefire if this happened to you but
they expect Israel to act by a certain
set of rules I think Israel needs to
eliminate Hamas without question
we think that we should go and tell
every government that's within that
territory Lebanon Syria that they need
to stay out of this we need to make sure
no taxpayer dollars go to any
Palestinian entities or any un entities
that support Hamas we need to make sure
that we are focused on giving all the
intelligence ammunition and equipment we
need um Israel needs to be able to
finish this and we need to freeze
Iranian assets the $6 billion dollars
but we also need to go back and put
strong sanctions like we had before
China is importing more Iranian oil than
anyone else Russia is getting drones and
missiles from Iran these three Russia
China and Iran know exactly what they're
doing America and the West needs to wake
up because we are too distracted and we
can't be so arrogant to think that this
can't happen on our soil we have to have
the backs of our friends we have to
understand it's not that Israel needs
America America needs Israel because
they are the first line of defense for
Islamic terrorism and we have to start
taking this seriously and all of this
we've seen chaos from the Democrats from
inflation and what they've done to Crime
on our streets to an open border to lack
of transparency and education to you
know chaos around the world but what we
have to remember as Republicans is the
one thing you don't do is we can't chase
Democrat chaos with Republican chaos we
have to start looking forward we have to
leave the negativity the baggage and the
headlines of the past and start
realizing this is a new world we're in
and this is evil and we have to have the
moral Clarity to know the difference
between good and bad between right and
wrong between good and evil this is true
evil that we're seeing and the top of
that ticket Joe Biden is the one that's
allowing all of these Democrats to act
this way because he did this to us he's
the one that loosened the sanctions
because he was falling all over himself
to get into the Iran deal he's the one
that made that terrible deal for $6
billion he's the one that took off and
has been silent the last couple of days
when we have nine Americans maybe 11
Americans that are hostages or died in
this situation and I'm sure there's more
a thousand of our greatest allies
citizens died and what are we doing not
enough we need to be there and let every
terrorist know we are going to hold
hands with Israel we're going to be
there with them you know why Saudi
Arabia and all the Arab countries have
pulled hold back because they don't
trust that America and Israel will win
we have to show them that we will win we
have to show them that we're committed
we have to show them we're no longer
distracted it is time for America to
pull this together it is time for
America to stop all these silly games
all these silly distractions and get to
work for the American people because our
national security is at risk and our
friends are at risk and we're watching
that happen right now and it's a tragedy
what should what should happen to Iran
real
quickly we have to stop Iran every
dollar they get goes to terrorism we had
totally eliminated their economy this
money doesn't go to feed their people it
goes to feed their terroristic Behavior
eliminate their economy make sure they
never get a bomb stop all the oil that's
going to China stop all the equipment
and ammunition that's going to Russia
and bring them to their knees and we
can't stop until we do that they have
been celebrating saying death to Israel
death to America don't ever forget that
death to Israel death to America they
hate us more than they hate Israel we've
got to put an end to this once and for
all well Israel's the the little Satan
where the big Satan right as BB often
has used that analogy uh Nikki Haley
thank you tonight we appreciate you
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else